well you've also said that covering war
and being in combat blows out your
levels and I thought that was a very
interesting way to put it that normal
life quote unquote is really never the
same so once that our decision came down
how was it for you to assimilate back
into life I exposure to risk absolutely
does blow out your levels and it makes
everything else look pretty dull and
meaningless I think I mean the feeling
of meaningfulness comes from feeling
that there's consequences to things and
the greater the consequences are the
more meaning something seems to have and
the ultimate consequences are life and
death and so in a combat situation
everything seems incredibly meaningful
because the enormous consequences are
everywhere and then you come back to you
know your suburban home in America and
nothing seems very meaningful because
the consequence is we've made it a
society where consequences are kept to a
minimum which is great except that it
feels meaningless and I think the trick
to living happily in that kind of
situation is to find other kinds of
other kinds of meaning you know you know
walk in the park with your child is very
meaningful but there's no risk involved
there's no consequences really involved
and I think it's a matter of maturing of
maturity to grow out of a 20 year old or
a 30 year old mindset about excitement
and risk and consequence into something
a little bit more profound and for me I
don't know if I'm late or early but I
started that process in my late 40s and
I'm getting there and actually you know
I think I have a certainly less exciting
life but I think I have a much richer
life emotionally richer life that I ever
could have had jetting off to war zones
and coming back all cranked with
adrenaline
you